Nous allons reprendre la confession de foi.
Et juste un rappel, la confession de foi n'est pas inspirée,
elle n'est pas la Bible,
mais elle représente l'expression de l'obéissance
de plusieurs passages dans les Écritures
qui ordonnent l'Église à préserver l'Évangile, les trésors
et les passer aux prochaines générations avec fidélité.
Donc les formulations des crédeaux et des confessions,
elles en général vont apparaître dans des circonstances
où des hérésies s'opposent à l'enseignement clair des Écritures
et l'Église se rassemble pour définir de manière concise et précise
ce qui est le clair enseignement des Écritures.
Et les confessions se préoccupent en général
à décrire les vérités les plus importantes à propos de la foi chrétienne.
Voilà pourquoi je vous fais un rappel des chapitres
qu'on a déjà traversés avant d'arriver à ces chapitres.
Nous sommes devant les chapitres 6 de la confession de foi
de 1689 de Londres,
la confession baptiste des fois.
Et nous avons commencé par les Écritures saintes.
Donc nous avons impérativement besoin d'un livre qui soit inspiré et fiable
car aucun être humain peut réclamer de soi-même la certitude
d'interprétation
pour décrire qui Dieu est
ou quels sont les moyens de salut.
Et s'il n'a plus à Dieu de se révéler,
nous avions besoin de cette révélation
pour avoir une base d'autorité sécurisée
pour connaître Dieu
avec certitude,
que Dieu décrive lui-même qui l'est avec précision
car notre condition pécheresse nous empêche
non de reconnaître
quelques vérités certaines à propos de Dieu,
mais nous sommes pliés par notre corruption
à toujours tâcher l'image de Dieu,
changer l'image de Dieu,
domestiquer Dieu,
supprimer la vérité
car on préfère l'injustice.
Et donc la Bible, elle est
ces livres que Dieu nous a donnés
car c'était un besoin
si jamais on avait l'espoir
de restaurer notre connaissance de Dieu
et de comprendre de quelle manière
on peut être sauvé.
C'est ça,
le thème principal des Écritures,
c'est l'autorévélation de Dieu
de manière objective et précise
à propos des choses les plus importantes
sur Dieu et sur notre salut.
Ce n'est pas le seul moyen
de connaissance de Dieu.
Dieu a deux livres, comme on dit,
la création et la révélation spéciale
qui est la Bible,
mais à cause de notre corruption,
nous ne faisons pas un bon usage
de la création
pour arriver à quelques connaissances
et la création,
elle est suffisante pour nous condamner,
mais elle n'est pas suffisante
pour nous révéler
un moyen de réconciliation.
Donc la révélation publique
est nécessaire
pour qu'on soit précis
dans notre connaissance de Dieu,
pour qu'on restaure
notre connaissance de Dieu,
mais pour qu'on connaisse aussi
les vrais moyens de salut.
Et donc la Bible,
c'est là où ça commence.
Et c'était un mouvement
contre l'hérésie catholique
de réclamer autorité d'inspiration
sur les doctrines
de l'Église,
des prêtres,
du clergé,
et surtout contre
les papes qui réclamaient
l'inspiration,
l'autorité d'inspiration
dans ces paroles.
Et donc les réformateurs,
ils sont revenus
à cette doctrine basilaire
de la foi historique,
car les cinq premiers siècles
de l'Église
ont toujours affirmé
« Voici les canons,
voici ce qui est
la Bible inspirée. »
Et les livres apocryphes
étaient considérés
comme des auteurs canoniques,
des livres d'importance historique,
intéressants,
mais qui n'ont jamais été comparés
à l'inspiration
des livres qui étaient reconnus.
Et donc on revient
à la seule autorité des Écritures
et c'était les premiers paragraphes
qu'on a considérés.
Ensuite on a considéré
la Saint-Trinité.
Donc c'est la doctrine sur Dieu
et sur la Saint-Trinité.
Et donc,
pour une question des nécessités,
on doit commencer
pour être bien affirmé
dans toutes les évidences bibliques
que la Bible éteint l'autorité suprême
réclame son autorité elle-même
et pour plus que notre foi
puisse être légèrement fortifiée
par des évidences externes,
comparer la Bible
avec n'importe quel autre livre
et la transcription
et la transmission de la Bible
avec n'importe quelle autre
transmission historique.
Donc la Bible,
elle sort des lois
avec des évidences externes
qui montrent son autorité,
son inspiration.
Mais l'autorité suprême
étant la Bible elle-même,
le plus important c'est de considérer
c'est que la Bible elle-même
parle de soi-même
et elle se présente
comme autorité suprême.
Et donc par nécessité,
on a besoin de dire
où nous allons apprendre sur Dieu.
Par contre,
les festants
de l'âme humaine,
de l'expérience humaine,
c'est de se plonger
dans la connaissance de Dieu.
Il est la source
de toute la gloire,
il est la source
de toutes bonnes choses,
de tous les biens
et les biens suprêmes.
Donc il n'y a aucun domaine
d'études
qui soit plus plaisant,
plus glorieux
qui étudier tout simplement
qui Dieu est
et qui Dieu est
dans la beauté
de sa Trinité.
C'est ce qu'on a fait.
On a étudié
l'être des dieux,
les attributs des dieux
et ensuite on est passé
à considérer
les œuvres des dieux.
Car Dieu
s'est fait connaître
en décrivant
sa gloire et sa beauté
par toutes les facettes
de ses attributs glorieux.
Mais Dieu révèle
sa gloire aussi
de manière très interactive
avec cet univers
par la manière
dont il a créé
toutes les choses.
Déjà,
cet univers
démontre
de manière très évidente
qu'il a été
un univers planifié.
Cela s'éprouve
par l'intelligence
derrière la réalité.
Cela s'éprouve aussi
par la manière
très sage
dont Dieu conduit
l'histoire.
Ce sont des évidences
que nous avons
autour de nous
à la mesure
où l'histoire
de l'humanité
se développe.
La création
et l'histoire
montrent
de manière
très évidente
et nous qui avons
les privilèges
de contempler encore
les Écritures,
la notion
des prophéties
accomplies
qui preuvent
que cet univers
a été tellement
bien planifié.
Dieu a donc
décrété les choses,
il a planifié
les choses
avant de les mettre
en exécution.
Dieu n'a pas
un plan B,
car il est
omniscient,
il est parfait
dans sa connaissance.
Donc,
Dieu a acquis
un plan A
et l'histoire
se développe
exactement
de la manière
dont Dieu
l'a planifié.
Car
il a décrété
toutes les choses
avant la première action
créationnelle,
mais car aussi
étant Dieu
bien présent,
nous ne sommes pas
déistes
où Dieu
donne une corde
dans l'horloge
et va s'abstenir.
Nous croyons
dans un Dieu
omniprésent,
un Dieu
qui gouverne.
Et donc,
on a considéré
d'abord
comment Dieu
a planifié
toutes les choses
et ensuite,
on a considéré
la doctrine
de la création.
C'était la quatrième
doctrine
qu'on a considérée.
Et là,
on a été
explicitement
en train
de défendre
la seule
interprétation
véritablement
honnête
lorsqu'on va
traiter
avec la clarté
des écritures
et les traitements
internes
des écritures.
Des personnes
peuvent avoir
d'autres positions
possiblement honnêtes
s'ils n'ont pas
fait un travail
honnête
de parcourir
toute la Bible
et l'histoire
de l'Église
pour chercher
à voir
comment la Bible
interprète la Bible.
et nous déclarons
fermement
que c'est une question
confessionnelle,
c'est-à-dire
l'Église
orthodoxe
depuis
les périodes
de l'Ancien Testament,
du Nouveau Testament
et l'histoire
de l'Église,
les Églises
confessionnelles,
l'intentionnalité
originelle
de ceux
qui ont rédigé
les confessions
des fois,
ils n'étaient pas
en train d'ouvrir
une possibilité,
par exemple,
pour que les six jours
de création
ne soient pas
interprétés
comme six jours
littéraux.
Quelle était
l'intentionnalité
des auteurs
des confessions
dans l'unanimité,
c'était de toujours
vouloir communiquer
par ces six jours,
six jours littéraux.
Voilà pourquoi
on peut dire
ouvertement,
même si certains
aujourd'hui vont dire
la confession de foi,
elle dit tout simplement
six jours,
mais il y a de la marge
pour interpréter
symboliquement six jours.
c'est malhonnête,
car nous devons
traiter les textes
en accord
avec l'intentionnalité
des auteurs.
Et si nous prenons
les enseignements
des auteurs
qui ont participé
à la rédaction
des confessions
des fois,
leur intentionnalité
était toujours
de signifier
un créationnisme
ex nihilo,
à partir de rien,
une terre jeune,
six jours littéraux
des créations.
Ça, c'est la doctrine
confessionnelle de l'Église
et ça, c'est la confirmation
intrascripturaire
qui a beaucoup plus
d'autorité
que l'histoire de l'Église.
Donc, la Bible,
dans son ensemble,
va traiter Genèse
comme historique,
comme littérale.
Donc, on a vu ça,
ça c'est très important
car l'une des manières
de Satan
de jouer
dans notre génération
avec toute cette notion
de tordre la réalité
l'identité des genres,
etc.,
tout dépend
d'une base littérale,
historique
sur laquelle
on doit défendre.
Donc, un homme
qui est assassiné,
et on va suggérer
qu'il a été assassiné
par des raisons politiques.
Les motivations spécifiques
de cet homme-là
qui est assassiné
étaient liées
à une relation
avec un homme transgenre.
Et cet homme
qui a été assassiné
et même si on peut
avoir quelques désaccords
avec quelques questions politiques,
nous ne pouvons pas
avoir des désaccords
avec ces convictions
bibliques
enracinées
dans la parole de Dieu.
Et de se positionner
envers la réalité
pour défendre
l'ordre des dieux
pour ce qui est au cœur
de l'image des dieux
dans l'homme,
c'est-à-dire la masculinité
et la féminité,
les complémentarismes bibliques,
ce n'est pas tout simplement
une question politique.
c'est de défendre
la vérité biblique.
Et donc ici,
quand on voit
la réalité
dans laquelle nous sommes,
nous dépendons
de cette restauration
des convictions bibliques
qui d'ailleurs
sont confirmées
par la science.
même si les propagandas
corrompus opposés
veulent suggérer
les contraires.
Donc on a vu
ces évidences
et on a considéré
surtout,
quand on a considéré
la création,
l'homme créé
à l'image
des dieux.
Quelle position glorieuse.
Il n'y a pas eu
d'évolution pour l'homme.
Aujourd'hui,
on verra qu'il y a eu
de l'involution,
de la décadence
pour l'homme.
On a vu littéralement
que tous ont été créés,
tous les êtres,
selon leur espèce.
Mais l'homme,
il a été créé
selon l'image des dieux.
La distinction
est explicite
dans la parole des dieux
et elle est évidente
dans la réalité.
Et ensuite,
on a traité
au chapitre 5
la doctrine
de la providence divine.
C'est quoi
la doctrine
de la providence divine ?
Donc,
c'est intéressant
car certains vont mettre
la providence
avant la création,
certains vont mettre
la providence
après la création.
Dans la confession,
c'est après la création.
Pour ceux qui mettent
la providence
avant la création,
c'est pour suggérer
et donner encore plus
d'évidence
que l'homme était
quelque part
au centre
de cet univers
créé,
Dieu,
au centre bien sûr,
mais l'homme en tant qu'image
pour représenter Dieu,
il était l'apothéose
de la création.
Et c'est clair
que Dieu
a planifié
les fonctionnements
des planètes,
l'équilibre
de l'univers,
il a préparé
la naissance
de toutes les herbes,
les animaux,
etc.
Tout était en train
de rendre
évidence
que Dieu
était en train
de mettre en marche
un univers
qui serait en train
de fonctionner
pour fournir
à l'homme
ce dont il aurait
besoin
pour vivre
et pour glorifier Dieu
dans son interaction
avec cet univers.
Et donc,
la providence
parle
de cette provision
dans l'univers
en bon fonctionnement
qui servira
comme
les théâtres
sur lesquels
la gloire des dieux
dans l'homme
va briller.
Mais la providence,
elle va au-delà
tout simplement
de cette manière
dont Dieu
établit
les lois
des continuités
d'existence.
La providence
parle d'un Dieu
bien présent
qui est non seulement
en train de soutenir
le fonctionnement
de toutes ces machines
qui fonctionnent
dans l'univers
dans cet équilibre parfait
les lois
qu'il a établies
pour régir
cet univers
les lois
même dans nos corps
personnels
et tous les fonctionnements
qu'on a
mais c'est un Dieu
bien présent
en train de gouverner
sur la libre
agence
des êtres créés.
Et donc,
on a considéré
que la providence
des dieux
elle va
concerner
les actes
les plus fortuites
de cet univers
les épisodes
les plus tragiques
car il a
la capacité
de réclamer
sa justice
et de converger
les mâles
en bien
pour afficher
sa gloire.
Donc,
Dieu fait
toutes les choses
en accord
avec sa nature
infiniment sainte
et infiniment belle
et infiniment bonne
et si nous avons
du mal
à interpréter
les faits,
les épisodes,
les évidences,
c'est un problème
à nous,
c'est notre limitation.
Dieu aura
toujours la capacité
de réclamer
sa gloire
dans la manière
dont il conduit
chaque épisode
de nos vies.
Et donc,
on a considéré
la providence
qui est l'une
des doctrines
les plus
réconfortantes
pour les chrétiens
car Dieu
gouverne
toutes les choses
avec une attention
spéciale
consacrée
au bien-être
et à la promotion
de son église.
Et donc,
en ayant considéré
la providence
et notamment
la doctrine
sur l'homme,
la providence,
elle nous a un peu
préparés
à comprendre
comment même
l'épisode
de la chute
se passe
sous les gouvernements
des dieux.
Il n'y a aucune chose
qui puisse prendre
Dieu par surprise.
même si Dieu n'est jamais
l'auteur direct
du mal,
il va toujours
gouverner
sur les agents
du mal
afin de conduire
le mal
envers les biens.
Et donc,
aujourd'hui,
on rentre
dans cette doctrine
qui est la doctrine
sur la chute
de l'homme,
les péchés
de l'homme
et son châtiment.
Et donc,
je vais juste
lire les premiers
paragraphes
pour faire
une petite introduction.
Donc,
la confession de foi,
chapitre 6,
paragraphe 1.
Voici
ces paragraphes
très concis.
Bien que Dieu
ait créé
l'homme droit
et parfait
et lui ait donné
une loi juste
qui était en vue
de la vie
s'il avait
été observé
et qu'il allait
et pardon,
et qu'il ait
menacé des morts
s'il la transgressait,
l'homme n'a pas gardé
longtemps
cet honneur.
Utilisant
subtilement
les serpents,
Satan
séduisit
Ève
et par elle,
il séduisit
Adam
qui,
sans contrainte
sur lui,
transgressa
volontairement
la loi
de leur création
et les commandements
qui leur avaient
été donnés
en mangeant
du fruit
défendu.
Il a plu à Dieu
de permettre
cette chute
dans son conseil
sage et saint
puisqu'il avait
déterminé
de l'utiliser
pour manifester
sa gloire.
Voici la déclaration
qui est très biblique
qui nous lance
dans cette réflexion
sur l'un des sujets
les plus importants
à saisir
en tant qu'être humain
et en tant que chrétien.
Donc c'est très important
pour nous aujourd'hui
de comprendre déjà
l'importance
de l'ordre
vis-à-vis
la compréhension
de la chute.
Dans quel sens
quand on considère
que les Écritures
sont inspirées
par Dieu,
nous ne pouvons pas
subir à la tentation
de chercher
à interpréter
différemment les choses
de sortir
à la défense
de Dieu
comme si on était
son avocat.
Ça c'est l'une
des plus grandes tentations
de certains chrétiens
avec des bonnes motivations.
Ils ne veulent pas
reconnaître
la totale
omniscience des dieux
ou la totale
souveraineté des dieux
ou les décrets
des dieux
car dans les décrets
des dieux,
dans la souveraineté
dans la providence
des dieux,
il a inclus
la chute
de l'humanité.
Mais si Dieu
est en train de dire
moi je suis
l'auteur des Écritures,
je sais très bien
défendre ma gloire.
Et si nous faisons
les bons travails
étape par étape,
il faut qu'on se rappelle
de quelle manière
Dieu a créé
toutes les choses.
Qui était Dieu ?
Quelles étaient les existences
des dieux ?
Et donc,
les catégories
lorsqu'on se voit
devant des questions
complexes,
des crises
existentielles,
théologiques,
il faut qu'on recule
et qu'on revienne
aux catégories
des bases.
Qu'est-ce que la Bible
enseigne
de manière plus explicite,
de manière plus claire ?
Je dois douter
de mes doutes
et considérer
par exemple
qu'est-ce qu'on a
médité à propos
des dieux
et de la Santé
qui est un peu
d'une opportunité ?
Dieu est infiniment
sans,
Dieu est bon,
Dieu est tout-puissant.
Aucun épisode historique
ne peut aller
contre ce qui Dieu est.
Sinon,
Dieu n'est plus Dieu.
Vous comprenez ?
Voilà pourquoi Paul
n'a pas peur
d'oser à nous présenter
la situation
de ces jumelles
qui n'étaient même
pas encore nées
pour qu'elles aient
fait les biens
ou les mals
pour être la base
d'une élection
et ils s'aimaient
à notre place
comme si on était
au bord
de dire une blasphème.
Donc,
Dieu est injuste.
Et Paul
va faire taire
à ses auditeurs
en disant
qui es-tu,
oh homme,
pour se discuter
avec Dieu ?
Nous ne sommes
qu'és
de la poussière
qui a été créée
par Dieu
par pure grâce
qui a reçu
les privilèges
de vivre
dans cet univers
glorieux
importants
en son image.
Dieu nous a élevés
des riens,
de la poussière.
Et voilà pourquoi
Paul va dire ça.
Comment les vases
peuvent se demander
à celles
qui l'ont fait
pourquoi tu m'as fait ainsi ?
Voilà ce qui nous sommes.
Rien élevé.
Mais ce qu'on verra
aujourd'hui,
c'est notre responsabilité
de notre chute.
de ne pas avoir fait
un bon usage,
de ne pas avoir chéri
cette condition glorieuse.
D'être nous-mêmes
les êtres humains
les responsables
de notre condition
et d'exiger
aux demandes saintes
d'un Dieu
saint et pur
d'agir proportionnellement
à notre rébellion.
la poussière
qui méprise
cette place glorieuse,
la communion
avec Dieu
et qui passe
à commettre
la plus grande injustice.
Car tout péché
n'est pas mesuré
par la comparaison
entre nos péchés
ou avec Hitler
par exemple,
mais les péchés
les sont mesurés
par rapport à Dieu.
L'être
le plus aimable,
l'être
qui nous aime
le plus,
l'être
le plus digne
d'amour,
d'adoration,
des services
et c'est lui
qui possède
toute autorité.
Donc la moindre
mépris des dieux,
la moindre rébellion
contre Dieu
est digne
d'une punition
proportionnelle
à son infinie dignité,
à son infinie position
des juges
et des justices
et voilà pourquoi
l'enfer
n'est jamais exagéré.
Et donc,
cet ordre
théologique
introduit la chute
juste après
la considération
glorieuse
du privilège
qu'a été
notre création
et de la position
tellement élevée
dans laquelle
on a été mis
pour démontrer
comment notre rébellion
est
souprimement
abominable.
Un mépris
de la source
de tous les biens,
un mépris
de la communion
avec Dieu,
un mépris
d'une soumission
volontaire
envers les créateurs,
un manque
de confiance
envers celui
qui nous a fait
de manière
si glorieuse.
donc la chute
de l'homme
elle vient
après qu'on ait
bien réfléchi
et tout ce qu'on peut
expérimenter
des bons
et des glorieux
dans cette vie
est crédité
à la grâce
condescendante
des dieux
envers nous
et notre contribution
dans cette histoire
était les péchés
et la rébellion.
Il n'y a pas
de victimisme
c'est comme la réponse
d'Assist Pro
ce n'est pas exagéré
que l'être humain
en ayant mangé
un fruit
soit envoyé
à l'enfer
ou pourquoi
et là sa réponse
elle est glorieuse
il va dire
comment
oserait-il
toi qui as
de la bouée
croire
que
la rébellion
d'une puissière
contre un dieu
si glorieux
soit impétitueuse
et ensuite
quand quelqu'un
posait la question
pourquoi
les choses injustes
se passent
avec les personnes
justes
sa réponse
c'est là
ça n'a qu'eut lieu
une fois
et lui
il s'est porté
volontaire
pour souffrir
cette injustice
il n'y a
aucune souffrance
aucune injustice
qu'on vit dans cette vie
qui soit à la hauteur
de ce qu'on mériterait
si Dieu nous traitait
purement
avec de la justice
on serait tous
en enfer
et nous ne pouvons pas
comprendre
cette réalité
si nous sommes déjà
très susceptibles
aux pressions
de notre culture actuelle
qui encourage
les victimismes
et qui cherche
à donner
une importance
et une telle importance
par les développements
personnels
même à l'église
que nous n'avons pas
dans notre condition actuelle
l'importance
que nous avons
en tant que autrement
c'est l'importance
que Dieu nous a
crédité en tant que son image
et l'importance
qu'il a déterminé
à réconcilier
sur un très haut prix
et donc
c'est très important
de revenir
à ces catégories
pour nous rappeler
dans quel état
où l'aurait été créé
et quel est
et quels sont
les attributs
des dieux
en tant que saint
et donc
la proposition
pour aujourd'hui
c'est tout simplement
de faire une introduction
à la structure
de la confession
des fois
et une ambiétation
avec les textes bibliques
de la chute
mais avant de passer
à la considération
du texte
c'est toujours
très important
d'avoir
un rappel
sur l'attitude
avec laquelle
nous nous approchons
de certaines doctrines
c'était la même chose
quand on s'approche
de Dieu
et la Saint-Trinité
comme Moïse
on doit enlever
les sandales
reconnaître
qu'il y en a des vents
enterrants solennels
et s'approcher
des dieux
l'objectif de la théologie
c'est
contact avec Dieu
pour l'adorer
pour avoir de la communion
avec lui
c'est sa condescendance
qu'il a fait
écrire
la Bible
interagir
avec notre histoire
et écrire la Bible
afin de se révéler
et s'il décrit
la chute
qui peut être
peut être gênante
dans notre génération
à cause
de notre vision tordue
de ce qu'est l'homme
c'est en même temps
une manifestation
de l'amour
de Dieu
qui nous traite
avec franchise
car ceux
qui ne connaissent
pas leur maladie
ne cherchent pas
la bonne guérison
et donc
nous nous approchons
en reconnaissant
les mystères
l'une des questions
les plus difficiles
et nous devons
les reconnaître
c'est
comment Dieu
peut permettre
que la chute
ait lieu
s'il est un Dieu
souverain
bon et saint
on n'arrive pas
à harmoniser
de manière immédiate
ensuite
cette question
c'est une question
pour laquelle
on n'a même pas
de réponse
de quelle manière
les péchés
rentrent dans le cœur
de l'homme
si l'homme
était moralement
parfait
à l'origine
on a des conjectures
mais la Bible
elle est très claire
pour expliciter
que Dieu
n'est pas
l'auteur du mal
et qu'il ne tente
personne
donc nous devons
reconnaître
que Dieu
a laissé
quelques mystères
non répondus
mais ces choses
ne peuvent jamais
être une excuse
pour ne pas se plonger
dans l'enseignement
public
car si Dieu
l'a révélé
c'est car
il y a un grand gant
pour notre salut
et quels sont
les gants
d'étudier
cette doctrine
déjà
c'est impossible
de comprendre
l'homme
sans ses compléments
on a dit
la même chose
dans le passé
donc c'est de la méchanceté
donner aux personnes
l'impression
que
la vraie liberté
soit
la liberté
de l'autonomie
c'est-à-dire
de créer
ses propres normes
de chercher
à vivre
une vie
selon
des normes
imaginées
par un homme
corrompu
une femme
corrompue
qui sort du cadre
de la norme
naturelle
c'est de la méchanceté
car la réalité
a une liberté
très définie
telle qu'établie
par Dieu
et la liberté
va toujours
dans la direction
de la promotion
de la vraie vie
de la vraie joie
et c'est
autodestructeur
de chercher
à vivre
dans un imaginaire
qui est contraire
à la normalité
des dieux
c'est contre
sa propre joie
de chercher
à vivre
différent
de ce que Dieu
a créé
en tant qu'homme
et en tant que femme
c'est du vrai
amour
d'avertir
dans sa direction
et d'agir
en tant qu'homme
tel que la Bible
décrit
et c'est pour
notre propre bien
sauf qu'il ne suffit pas
tout simplement
de considérer
la manière
dont on a été créé
sinon la chose
serait réglée
beaucoup plus vite
beaucoup plus simple
il faut qu'on comprenne aussi
que l'être
où il est aujourd'hui
rempli
tellement de crises
car il y a
des restes
des désirs
plus nobles
des aspirations
plus élevées
qui ne peuvent
qu'être justifiées
par la création
car la réalité
empirique
de l'être humain
dans l'histoire
dès que l'histoire
est enregistrée
par l'être humain
et nous savons très bien
que l'histoire
est enregistrée
dès le début
nous ne croyons pas
à la préhistorique
ou des choses comme ça
des airs
et dès que l'histoire
est enregistrée
l'histoire est marquée
par péché
corruption
guerre
et donc l'homme
a cette crise
d'existence
qu'il a
une soif
pour être infini
sachant qu'il est
périssable
que la vie
est courte
que nous sommes
éphémères
quelle crise
tous les êtres humains
font face
et l'autre crise
ce sont des crises
qui sont abordées
même par la philosophie
c'est la crise morale
de l'homme
nous n'arrivons même pas
à vivre
en accord
avec les aspirations
de notre propre conscience
nous sommes
à chaque jour déçus
avec le fait
qu'on est exposé
à des maladies
qu'on est en train
de veillir
nous sommes humiliés
par un arbre
qui va vivre plus que nous
et nous cherchons
de nous cacher
de couvrir
des gloires
distraire les yeux
de personnes
de cette réalité
et en même temps
non seulement
nous voyons
ces pourrires extérieures
mais nous contemplons
les pourrires intérieures
et donc c'est impossible
de comprendre
l'état actuel
de l'homme
ces crises
car l'homme
il essaye
d'expliquer
de plusieurs manières
pour certains
plus religieux
c'est la notion
de cette
dichotomie
de l'univers
les biens et les mal
qui vivent avec
vivent ensemble
qui font partie
de la nature
et nous sommes
ces êtres dissonants
les consolations
de la psychanalyse moderne
qui va suggérer aussi
que nous sommes
plutôt des malades
lorsque
ces choses cohabitent
très récurrents
dans nos vies
on va nommer
comme si on était
schizophréniques
bipolaires
et on aimerait bien
embrasser
ces diagnostics
qui peut-être
parfois
sont raisonnables
mais qui d'entre nous
n'est pas déçu
surtout avant la conversion
avec ses propres
oscillations comportementales
et qui d'entre nous
n'aimerait avoir
une excuse
médicale
pour ne pas
se responsabiliser
de sa manque
de maîtrise
ou d'assumer
véritablement
ces corruptions
il y a la théorie
de l'évolution
qui va suggérer
tout simplement
que ce sont
les restes
de nos instants
animaux
encore une belle excuse
et pour certains
philosophes
qui vont dans la direction
de l'existentialisme
comme Sartre
ou Nietzsche
pourvu que la création
originaire
n'est pas issue
des dieux
toute moralité
et aspiration
humaine
plus élevée
n'ont pas de sens
et pour eux
c'est ça
leur déclaration
et c'est ça
les fruits
que nous vivons
aujourd'hui
de nos sociétés
la vraie liberté
c'est l'autonomie
sans se laisser imposer
par des codes sociaux
être ce que nous voudrons être
et satisfaire la volonté
peu importe la direction
qu'elle pointe
mais la réalité
c'est que
l'expérience
de ces crises
elle est universelle
Jonathan Edwards
il a dit
peut-être que pour
la création
on doit faire
un petit travail
apologétique
ou peut-être
que pour
l'expiation
du Christ
ou la résurrection
on doit faire
un travail
historique
et apologétique
pour convaincre
les personnes
par contre
la doctrine
de la chute
du péché
c'est une expérience
empirique
universelle
dont les évidences
sont explicites
l'histoire
de la chute
de la humanité
attachées par
l'immoralité
par les sangs
par l'adultère
même si
la plupart
des codes
moraux
de presque
toutes les sociétés
ont beaucoup
en commun
avec les dix commandements
quelles sociétés
vont s'opposer
qui sait bien
de ne pas avoir
des voleurs
de respecter
la propriété
privée
ou
quelle société
va traiter
la fidélité
conjugale
comme empêchée
donc
nous voyons
de manière très claire
que l'état
actuel
de l'être humain
exige
une explication
et la seule
explication satisfatoire
!
c'est l'explication
biblique
nous ne pouvons pas
comprendre
l'état
de la création
aujourd'hui
c'est intéressant
comme nous
on essaye
de réparer
des choses
qui sont évidemment
au-delà
de notre capacité
de réparer
on essaye
de les traiter
de manière très superficielle
car nous essayons
d'accepter
notre réalité
car on ne trouve
pas la solution
en nous-mêmes
et nous sommes encore
passionnés
par cette même corruption
par les péchés
l'être humain
sans l'évangile
et en plus
c'est l'être humain
lui-même
selon la Bible
qui a porté
sur la création
ces problèmes
qu'on essaie
de régler
avec toute cette
phase écolo
donc nous ne pouvons
pas comprendre
la création
telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
avec
les événements
qui rendent évident
que la terre
elle n'est plus
comme à l'état
original
où elle nous servait
volontiers
mais nous
nous l'avons
rendu
otage
à cause
de notre péché
car nous
étions
les représentants
des dieux
pour cette création
et donc
il y a
cette opposition
cette difficulté
de s'aimer
qui est liée
notamment
à cette chute
nous ne pouvons
pas comprendre
la bataille
interne
et la bataille
externe
de l'être humain
nous ne pouvons
pas comprendre
l'incrédulité
et les crises
existentielles
de l'être humain
malgré toute évidence
malgré la conscience
roman
nous dit clairement
nous préférons
supprimer
ces évidences
nous ne pouvons
pas comprendre
l'évangile
ni l'évangélisation
car quelqu'un
a déjà dit
c'était une crise
si je ne me trompe pas
c'est Tinkala
qui présente
cette crise
d'un homme
qui était même
il avait gagné
un prix Nobel
et sa crise
il disait
qu'il ne pouvait pas
croire en Dieu
car il ne pouvait pas
imaginer comment
l'homme tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui
dans cette crise
entre sa noblesse
et sa crotté
ait été créé
par un tel Dieu
qui a mis
des aspirations
en nous
envers
la moralité
envers un monde
mieux
et qui en même temps
ne nous a pas
donné la capacité
de vivre à la hauteur
de cette réalité
et les problèmes
c'est
les manques
d'informations
par rapport
à la discontinuité
de l'être humain
donc la création
est une partie
de la vérité
mais la chute
est une autre partie
nous ne pouvons pas
comprendre
l'être humain
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
si cette description
de la chute
n'est pas
historiquement fiable
car l'homme
le problème
c'est que
oui Dieu a créé
l'homme avec des aspirations
et la capacité
de vivre
mais nous nous sommes
mis dans une condition
où on a perdu
radicalement
cette possibilité
de vivre à la hauteur
de notre conscience
et donc nous ne pouvons
pas comprendre
l'évangile
car il y a
cette notion
de représentation
fédérale
qu'on va mieux comprendre
d'Adam
tant qu'il représentant
de toute la race
liée à notre chute
mais aussi
et voilà pourquoi
les personnes
qui vont avoir
des réticences
par rapport
à cette doctrine
de la représentation
fédérale
ils n'auraient pas
ils disent
ils n'auraient pas aimé
être représenté
par Adam
la vérité
c'est que
si on était
à sa place
la seule différence
c'est qu'on allait
tomber plus vite
c'est Dieu lui-même
les justes
qu'il a choisi
pour être
notre représentant
il était
certainement
qualifié
mais la réalité
c'est que
si nous ne voulons
pas avoir
Adam
pour représentant
l'égal
nous ne pouvons
pas non plus
avoir Christ
pour représentant
l'égal
et donc
nous n'allons
jamais comprendre
l'évangélisation
car malheureusement
ce qui manque
beaucoup
dans l'évangélisation
ce qui démontre
la superficialité
et même
une des racines
de si tant
de fausses conversions
c'est des personnes
qui ne comprennent
pas la nécessité
absolue
de reconnaître
sa pauvreté
spirituelle
et de pleurer
à cause de sa condition
et de ses péchés
il n'y a pas
de bonnes nouvelles
s'il n'y a pas
la compréhension
de quelle est
la mauvaise nouvelle
et si nous ne
ne voyons pas
par la perspective
du péché
nous ne pouvons pas
comprendre
les vrais
évangiles
Jésus-t'aime
n'est pas
l'évangélisation
c'est une réalité
mais l'évangélisation
va bien au-delà
Jésus n'est pas
quelqu'un
qui vient tout simplement
pour améliorer
quelques aspects
de nos vies
il est
la force
contrôlatrice
de nos vies
car les jours
où on a compris
véritablement les crises
n'étaient pas
une option
parmi d'autres
il était
la corde de sauvetage
à laquelle
on a dû s'accrocher
car on a été
terrifié
de nous avoir vu
à la lumière
de la gloire de Dieu
d'avoir reconnu
la totale impossibilité
de mériter
cette réconciliation
et si ce n'était Christ
nous pourrions
nous conduire
nous même à l'enfer
comme ce que j'ai
cherché à y faire
et donc
nous n'allons jamais
comprendre
l'utilité
et les limitations
des débats
apologétiques
c'est très important
il y a des personnes
qui font tellement
confiance
à des débats
apologétiques
et chercher
à défendre la foi
par la raison
c'est à la force
de renforcer
une foi déjà existante
ça peut être
même utilisé
par les Saint-Esprits
envers l'évangélisation
mais la réalité
c'est que nous
devons comprendre
quel est
l'état présent
des interlocuteurs
son incapacité
comme on a vu
dans les cas
de l'éonoc-éthiopien
c'est surtout
la présentation
de l'évangile
frontale
qui est beaucoup
de confiance
dans nos capacités
d'argumenter
à faveur de la foi
et je suis passionné
par l'apologétique
elles sont très utiles
parfois
pour la compréhension
de la vision
des mondes
de l'interlocuteur
qui nous devons déconstruire
elles sont
parfois utiles
pour l'évangélisation
mais elles sont
beaucoup plus indiquées
dans la Bible
comme quelque chose
qui renforce
et scientifie
Christ
dans mon cœur
plutôt
qui est capable
d'échanger
la condition
des morts
spirituelles
c'est comme
la vision
des équiles
des os
desséchés
et c'est
la puissance
de Saint-Esprit
qui peut tourner
et donc c'est important
car
lorsque nous
avons
une meilleure idée
de la condition
radicale
de l'être humain
dans sa condition
de péché
et d'incrédulité
on fera
moins de confiance
sur ses stratégies
humaines
pour faire l'Église
ou l'évangélisation
et beaucoup plus
de confiance
à la puissance
des dieux
dans l'évangile
et les chrétiens
vont revenir
à la proclamation
frontale de Jésus
dans la société
nous ne pouvons pas
comprendre l'expérience
l'expérience
de l'évangile
et de la sanctification
ce n'est pas
qu'il comprendre
l'évangile
car l'évangile
doit être compris
par ses représentations
fédérales
dont je l'évoquais
l'expiation
substitutive
du Christ
mais l'expérience
des conversions
réelles
passe par
la répentance
la reconnaissance
de mon état
pécheur
et la sanctification
car même
après la conversion
il y a encore
les restes
des péchés
qui sont là
qui font la bataille
et nous ne pouvons pas
en tant que chrétiens
surtout en tant que chrétiens
nous cacher
derrière
les vitimismes
ou des maladies
c'est des péchés
on a vu ça
dans les œuvres
de la chair
toutes les choses
évoquées dans les œuvres
de la chair
sont appelées
péchés
pour qu'on sache
c'est responsabilisé
accès de colère
péché
excès de vent
gloutonalie
péché
donc un autre point
d'introduction important
c'est
comment considérer
comment nous devons considérer
l'abordage
historique
et littéral
des genèses
donc comme je vous ai dit
pour certains
une lecture très superficielle
il s'agit
tout simplement
d'une description allégorique
avec des principes
chrétiens derrière
pour d'autres
c'est un mythe
avec quelques vérités
illustrées
par une allégorie
ou un mythe
véritablement
pour certains
qui peuvent même
oser à croire
que c'est littéral
ils vont encore douter
si les serpents
ont véritablement parlé
ou si c'était plutôt
une personnification
du serpent
on essaie
de transporter
notre encre
de l'éternité
à la parole
le problème
c'est qu'à partir
du moment
où on traite
un passage
historique
comme allégorique
on ne sait jamais
quand est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir s'arrêter
on va se mettre
dans des contradictions
énormes
car plus tard
dans la Bible
dans plusieurs passages
ça sera traité
comme historique
et en réalité
c'est que nous
en tant que chrétiens
si nous sommes
véritablement convertis
qu'on croit
aux deux plus grands
miracles
la création
de l'univers
et la résurrection
du Christ
et si nous croyons
au diable
tel que la Bible
nous présente
et nous avons étudié
qu'est-ce qui pourrait
nous empêcher
de croire
au miracle
et au phénomène
surnaturel
et puissant
dans les nouveaux testaments
les démons
vont faire osage
de ces porceaux
vont se manifester
vont se communiquer
avec voix audible
quoi empêcherait
que Satan
soit en train
de faire osage
du corps
de ces serpents
et donc
la Bible
ne nous laisse pas
la possibilité
de ne pas interpréter
cet épisode
comme littéral
il est fondationnel
et fondamental
pour toute la suite
car juste après
la bataille
des sexes
des genres
elle a lieu
comme
punition
de la chute
et c'est là
où tout évangile
est basé
la représentation
fédérale
d'Adam
et du Christ
tout est fondamentalement
historique
nous ne pouvons pas
comprendre
pourquoi
même en ayant
la capacité
de reconnaître
l'ordre
biblique
créationnel
de comment
l'homme
devrait
conduire
protéger
et comment
la femme
devrait être là
pour être une aide
avec une même mission
une même dignité
et ça c'est une partie
de la compréhension
de ces aspirations
qui nous avons
encore aujourd'hui
lorsque nous sommes
exposés à ces vérités
les péchés au-dedans
de nous
peuvent vouloir résister
les péchés au-dedans
de nous
peuvent penser
que si nous changeons
les lois de la société
on va faire taire
à la conscience
qui crie
ou que lorsqu'un prédicateur
comme dans ces cas
commence à représenter
mes crises
des consciences internes
par les paroles externes
tout comme
les dix commandements
que Dieu donne
pour confirmer
la conscience
qui Romain en dit
qui fait partie
de tous les êtres humains
ne croyez jamais
qu'une personne
puisse être
cautérisée
à 100%
des dix commandements
qui sont au-dedans
d'eux-mêmes
et même
quand ils essayent
de crier
lorsqu'on peut
déjà respecter
tolérer
et accepter
certaines choses
qui ne correspondent
pas à la réalité
mais leur conscience
n'acceptait pas
voilà pourquoi
ils veulent toujours
aller plus loin
c'est comme s'ils voulaient
changer toute la réalité
et toute la société
afin
de valider
leur propre existence
d'aberration
et les problèmes
c'est que même
lorsqu'ils vont
exterminer
l'écho de la conscience
à l'extérieur
la chose ne fera
qu'ils grandir
au-dedans
de lui
c'est comme ça
que l'apôtre épaule
s'est converti
en s'opposant
frontalement
à Christ
dans son péché
et sa conscience
ne faisait qu'à
grandir
des coupabilités
et donc
quand on considère
la manière
dont la Bible
décrit
cet aspect
historique
et littéral
de l'épisode
de la chute
c'est une fondation
pour la compréhension
de nous
de qui nous sommes
de comment notre conscience
elle fonctionne
et de comment
après la conversion
on va lutter
contre les conséquences
de la chute
ce qui a conduit
à la chute
c'était l'inversion
de l'ordre créationnel
des dieux
dans la structure
du mariage
la conséquence
c'est cette bataille
qui va perdurer
et nous sommes
aujourd'hui
avec des aspirations
qui font la bataille
contre les péchés
qui ont été dans le monde
dans les choses
les plus basilières
de l'existence
la scientification
se trouve là
dans la structure
la plus essentielle
de l'être humain
dans son cadre familial
voilà pourquoi
c'est si tant attaqué
par Satan
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
et donc
je pense qu'au niveau
d'introduction
il nous reste
tout simplement
déclarer
qu'il s'agit
d'un fait historique
et l'autorité
suprême
pour ça
se trouve
dans la Bible
elle-même
lorsqu'elle va faire référence
et je vais vous citer
trois textes
pour finir
Job 31-33
si j'ai couvert
mes transgressions
comme Adam
en cachant
mon iniquité
dans mon sang
il traite
de manière littérale
l'épisode
de la chute
Osée chapitre 6
verset 7
mais ils ont
comme Adam
violé l'alliance
c'est alors
qu'ils m'ont
été infidèles
à nouveau
citation historique
de l'épisode
de la chute
deuxième Corinthien
11-3
mais j'écran
que comme les serpents
donc là c'est
mention littérale
du serpent
séduisit Ève
par sa ruse
ainsi vos pensées
ne se corromptent
en s'éloignant
de la simplicité
à l'égard
du Christ
encore un texte
1 Timothée 2
et Adam
n'a pas été séduisé
mais la femme
séduite
s'est rendue
coupable
des transgressions
et c'est pour
expliquer
la manière
dont les péchés
s'est développé
quand il écrit
à Timothée
il y a un autre passage
qui de manière indirecte
semble confirmer
l'aspect historique
et c'est notamment
la tentation
de Jésus au désert
il y a des comparaisons
très importantes
entre la chute
et la tentation
par laquelle
Jésus Christ
a été approuvé
en résistant
à cette tentation
nous allons voir
ces détails
plus tard
mais la réalité
c'est que
pour nous les chrétiens
ça devrait être
pathétique
sous la pression
des certains
intellectuels
résistants
au miracle biblique
de considérer
des difficultés
pour reconnaître
la description biblique
tellement explicite
tellement évidente
et tellement fondationnelle
pour la compréhension
et les développements
de l'histoire
et notamment
de l'évangile
donc nous devons
affirmer
et déclarer
et traiter
ces textes
comme un texte
littéral historique
et c'est ce qu'on fera
à partir de la semaine prochaine